hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to one late-night
deadlines okay so I'm starting to get
drowsy again as you all know but what I
do need is to find fit what is that the
laundry detergent dexterity yes what
does that even mean what is that
dexterity what is this an RPG why it's
so dark I don't understand I I don't get
it I'm not I'm not I'm not where am I oh
my god am I lost in the darkness
am I really lost in the darkness what
I'm lost in the dark I am I'm oh my god
I'm I'm I'm lost
somehow I got locked in here what why I
excuse me why why okay I don't have a
flashlight or anything
oh is that e okay here Oh God
oh I'm such an idiot oh man oh man oh
okay so I gotta find okay oh man I
I almost lost my mind there I apologize
okay I need to go to the floor with
apexis so if I get to the flow with
apexis it's either on the fourth floor
or something else I don't know
okay I'm gonna look in the sign down on
the first floor Wow I I apologize I
almost lost it there cuz holy crap
okay I think there was a sign on the
bottom floor I'm trying not to run too
much cuz I know it's gonna slow me down
eventually
I'll see a Pyxis where's the laser room
I don't know where the laser room is
where's the laser room it's us to make
any sense
what okay maintenance would be on the
bottom floor I assume but there's
nothing else here it's like nothing to
be had there can't be some small thing
that I missed right it wouldn't do that
to me it wouldn't be that big an ass
would it like I swear I looked through
all of this it looks to me you like this
would be a maintenance place but it's
not apparently maybe it's got to be on
the top floor or something like that I
haven't been I haven't really explored
the fourth floor so I'm gonna go up
there oh man I'm just so flabbergasted
I'm so full more not cold I'm so ably
ghibli like Raven what even and the
elevators don't work yeah let me just at
least explore a bit because as is as
I've been finding this small things here
and there I can pick up like possibly
key cards and whatever have you nothing
there no there's no point to any of this
there was no point there's no point any
that oh okay moving right along
also what is going on because I came in
on the first floor and yet here we are
on the bottom floor like I entered this
building through the lobby there's
obviously nothing above this like no
there's not but if I go up one floor I'm
willing to bet okay it's at zero but
it's hard
bet if I go up one floor like it's gonna
be different
oh okay there's front and back to the
belly okay never mind this this one
whatever whatever I'm just gonna go up
to the fourth floor try to explore
because frankly guys I'm at a loss I
wish I knew
I'm about to freak out I'm like two
steps from freaking out here at what the
hell's going on and I I don't know I
don't know I don't know I what was that
then I yawn I yawned but I don't know
guys I I wish I knew why is there a
laser lab in this building like I got a
keycard but it doesn't tell me when he
card is for there's no other explanation
it's just like that's it blow something
over here maybe there anything ah
anything that would be some sort of a
clue that's all I needed this point is
this clue and hope hope that it's gonna
be better the things are gonna be okay
now I'm gonna get through this and I
want to be alright that no one's gonna
hate me after I'm done because I missed
something horribly obvious and I'm going
to pax and I'm trying to have a good
time but I'm like ah I wanna know I
wanna play
why is this place foggy I don't know I
got a headache now this want to be good
at the game I just want to be good at
games I am good at games I'm good at
games
I swear I'm good at games I really am I
really am Here I am but only they
believe me so boy there's no point to be
here little boy little point any it is
what is that
then Easter Egg huh yeah I don't know
uh-uh
I don't know where I am I don't even
know why I'm here
do you know how to fix a goddamn vending
machine I tried to call but the phone
wouldn't work nothing works
I think alright alright I don't have a
plan I don't have an idea of what I'm
supposed to be doing I don't know what's
wait what's this
where is this another area another
vending machine does this one work
why there was one that worked the whole
time and you made me go around thinking
that I needed to fix that one what is
that a scream surely I couldn't have
imagined it
probably not but to save and move on oh
my god okay how how could they do that
to me how could they do that to me how
could they do that they had me believing
believing that there was only one
machine and I had to fix it I need a
different key card for this door oh oh I
have no objective right now I gotta go
find out what that scream was so first
interesting thing that's happened hello
who screamed I bet I can run now cuz I I
know where to get energy
sorry crotch check so what was that
scream sounded like it kind of came from
down in to the right a bit no from the
bathroom no really
ah there's no like navigation here
there's no clue as to where I need to go
it's all just form and it is it is what
it is and I can't do anything other than
just this
maybe I should operate under the
assumption that it was over here cuz I
can open this door
I hope this is like the first door I
ever opened and this is where led to the
other things I've seen before it looks
like something has been burnt on the
floor in there
the balloons gone the lights are on but
I see no one in there Oh easy are we
finally getting into the game here we
finally getting into the game we're only
40 minutes in oh my god it's the same
it's the original
it's what it was in the first game I'm
excited that's so excited I'm excited do
something give me give it to me I'm so
ready my body's ready I will take off my
pants right now
do something for me baby so great that's
all ready I'm ready
I'm waiting hmm that's cool
what's that this thing is I think Oh OOP
Robert ah Roberto got it okay so I got
Roberts key what does that mean can I
open Roberts office now
now what happened it's been so long
since I played the first game that I
don't actually know I won't actually
remember exactly the series of events
that led up to what happened
Robert Robert no use yeah there we go oh
it's dark in here
what's going on what's going on in here
huh
security level for input password
Hackett huh I can just hack it I'm not
good numpad locked what do you mean hey
I'm just a guy throwing a puzzle at me
took me a while to try to get what he
was doing hack it but uh boom I did it
okay I got the information you asked for
I don't know what you want with it
anyway it's a long close case anywhere
her name was Alva and her mother Lenore
seemed pretty twisted from what I could
gather she went into some deep
depression after her husband died and
took it out on her daughter she was
eventually admitted to a mental
institution but soon became fatally ill
and died when Alva was in her late teens
now much was see heard from Alba after
that until she was found dead I couldn't
find much details on how she died but
police reports claimed it was suicide
I guess the end elizabe
US had gotten the best of her and the
death of her mother was the final straw
okay
well that gives me some information well
what does that all mean why is there a
Ouija board here that was there before
in the first game I remember can I get
that no all right
nothing else there is that literally it
that was it
whoa I hear her knocks on the door she's
coming closer a ghost or the devil in
Vail good question
all good questions well now what do I do
what do I do now
how about an objective huh objective our
ever Jack t'v I need an average error
objective herb adjunctive herbs octave
bathroom bathroom
don't enter all right please what do i
do what do i do what do i do what do i
do what do i do what i do tell me what
do I want to do let me know what I need
to do freakin tell me oh look it's a
hang in there poster like Spooky's on in
mansion is it Oh big yawn yep right Rach
I didn't do something I didn't trigger
something I didn't do something small or
I missed something or I overlooked
something I needed to pick up like a key
card there must have been something else
in his office
I'm really sorry guys I'm really trying
I'm really trying not to overlook
anything I'm not trying to miss anything
I'm not trying to
what music start playing okay good why
is that CD something I can take looks
like an oh god I feel so dumb I feel so
dumb right now okay hello computer
ah okay this computer totally forgot
that this was a computer I could do okay
here we go what the Frick ah come on
there we go [ __ ] oh come on
ah uh-huh
oh boy
ah God what the hell oh wait I hacked in
what there are people in this world that
we do not seem to forget and cannot help
but create a bond to Robert warned me
about that warming not to get involved
lately I've been seeing more and more of
them ghosts and spirits that roam the
earth aimlessly what are ghosts really
empty energy just passing along our
memories that are looping endlessly
hoping to find a new owner
whatever they are they remind me they
remind me of when I last saw him his
eyes all right oh no oh no oh oh my
goodness oh my goodness my goodness
goodness
Oh
I love lawsuit I've completely lost it
get away
go away get out of my fur thank you god
damn it
wait was there there was a password here
I remember Kotkin bump right there there
there s chillon that's right the
password was echelon I got get up get
off oh it won't work anymore it's
totally broken now can't click on the
computer but I got the information
anyway I don't know why I was even
bothering to still try Oh what am i
doing
what am I doing with my life what am I
doing with anything in this game I don't
huh I've tried really hard I've tried
really hard to get this game going oh my
god I'm just dull man oh wow I feel like
a failure I feel like I'm just totally
an ass but I can't do it I can't do it I
gotta go I gotta get on a flight I got
like I got any of these at all these
episodes edit in like an hour and then
get him up ahh
ah ah oh man I wanted to LA I wanted to
get into I wanted to like it but oh my
god I've never seen the game with less
Direction less clarity less explanation
less fine-tuning I've oh my god
everything about this game should be
good but everything is so it's it's like
I I like the first game but this game is
so backwards from what it was like
everything is designed to not work it's
like the developer had a specific way
that he wanted things to go and he put
that in but there's so much more than it
just confuses everything and it can't be
explained as to what needs to be done at
any given time
I'm gonna save Ivan I'm gonna save my
game I'm gonna save my game I'm gonna
get some coffee in the other coffee room
that I didn't know about because how
else was I supposed to know about it
when I thought that I needed to fix the
other vending machine ah-ha I know right
God developer this game if you if you're
ever watching this I really am NOT
trying to be spiteful I have made
mistakes here but I as an average gamer
I'm really trying to play this game and
it shows something when I'm really
trying to get it and I'm really trying
to do it right and I still can't get it
and I get this aggravated like that
should say something I'm not trying to
say this is an awful game I can't say
that because I haven't been able to play
it though either way that's just all I'm
gonna say for now I gotta go check out
all the videos I've done the description
below see the original one late night
thank you all so much for bearing with
me through this once again in the
comments below
unleash everything that you want to say
to me if I was doing something totally
wrong the whole time if there was like a
button to hit for an objective menu
other than Oh which isn't even there
anymore
let me know please I want to know I want
to I want to play I want to play it so
bad I'm so sorry that I wasn't able to
I'm so sorry
it is what it is so thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
we'll see you in the next video bye-bye
all hail metal well I mean metal um very
useful there's various different types
of metal I only need one not oh god
that's bad they just turned horrible
he's gonna do I mean I wasn't told that
you're gonna be here your big freaking
sibling knows